We've got two out of our three asynchronous requests working.
Let's get some Wikipedia articles about the page to show up.
We're on the MediaWiki API page, because Wikipedia is run by MediaWiki, and
looking through this page, you'll actually find you don't need an API key.
However, making normal JSON requests to Wikipedia would result in a cross origin
or a cross-site error, because Wikipedia servers forbid cross origin requests.
There are several ways we can make this request to Wikipedia.
One would be to set the origin and
content type headers on the request and then Wikipedia would allow it.
Or, we can just use JSONP.
In our example, we'll be using JSONP.
A JSONP request is a somewhat convoluted trick
that involves a server wrapping the response inside a function to get
injected when it actually gets back to the client.
But luckily, if this sounds confusing, don't worry.
jQuery actually makes it pretty easy.
To make a JSONP request, we'll use the more robust .ajax method.
In fact, the .get JSON method we
were using before was actually just an abstraction of the .ajax method.
Which is, incidentally,
also an abstraction of an asynchronous JavaScript request.
For this quiz, use the .ajax method to collect data from a Wikipedia endpoint.
Let's take a look at the structure of the finished page.
We start off with a Wikipedia container that has all the links and
then inside of it we have this on sign list with an ID of Wikipedia links.
Going through the on sign list, we see just a couple list elements, and
then within each list element, we simply have an a tag with a link to Wikipedia.
Each A-tag of course contains the title of the Wikipedia article within it.
And like, you did before, for
this quiz you'll need to properly append the Wikipedia article to the page.
You'll need to include a few parameters within your Ajax request.
There will of course be a URL.
You'll need to include a dataType.
Notice, too,
in the signature we don't have an optional success function parameter.
Instead, you'll have to set it as a property.
Make sure your success parameter is set to a function that you want to
run when the request is returned successfully.
To start off, you'll fire off a JSON-P request using $.ajax, and
then into $.ajax.
You'll pass a settings object that will include a parameter for
data type and a parameter for success.
Once you get the response, iterate through it,
and then present articles on the page.
And, they should end up inside the unsigned list with the id of wikipedia-links.
When you're done, check this box.